sometimes it feels like life's biggest
mystery is finding out who you are and
because we're constantly learning and
growing and changing there's always a
new you to discover again and again and
again but in a society of limitless
choice it can be really difficult to
find you're saying we're in a world of
constant creation new trends new styles
new looks how do we keep up how do we
find what best represents who we are and
show that to the world because how we
look at ourselves in the mirror should
reflect how we truly feel on the inside
also thank you to SK 2 for sponsoring
today's episode and for years I feel
like I've struggled with what is my
style because there's this very valid
idea that how you present yourself
stylistically says a lot about who you
are as a person internally and I have
gone through the rigmarole of looks and
sometimes it seems like my friends know
who they are way better than I ever will
know myself like my friend Auden always
has a daily uniform she's in a jumpsuit
comfortable boots with her signature
Daria deadpan Claire my friend Dodie
seems like she was just born and
knee-high socks and adorable dresses and
my friend Savannah somehow manages to
make this whole plane tease tucked into
high-waisted jeans look both
sophisticated simple and very Steve Jobs
whereas me I feel like I kind of dress
up as a different character every day
depending on my mood I can't make up my
mind and what my style is more than I
can decide what my favorite food is or
my favorite TV shows are I feel like I'm
just constantly in flux not quite
settled into Who I am and for a long
time that's made me feel bad like I
never quite quit being the new kid and
it's only recently that I have started
to finally embrace this about myself
when I think about it like yeah you know
you grew up every two years moving to
different places and trying on different
aspects of your personality so why
wouldn't that continue as an adult and
I'm an actor so I wouldn't I love
playing dress-up every day and
discovering new characters may be a huge
part of who I am is that I'm always
changing and that's okay please to feel
this immense pressure that I had to like
define myself in this one way but that
definition is probably gonna change over
time what about you do you have like a
certain style do you feel like you need
to have a style cuz when I was email I
wanted everyone to know I was email more
by liner and whenever I went through a
big mental change I felt like I needed
to mirror that with a physical change
just as drastic less hair or do you feel
more comfortable with who you are and
what you look like being sort of like
more influx and going with the flow do
you not think at all about what your
style means or put any effort into it
because I think that says something
about you too I know I just find all of
that really fascinating and I'd be very
curious to hear what your approach is as
I mentioned earlier today's episode is
sponsored by SK too so throughout the
changes you make to find and keep up
with your authentic self don't forget to
take care of the foundation of what's
underneath yes Kim I was surprised to
find out that in America essences are a
relatively unknown product do you know
what in essence is because they've been
widely used in Asian countries for ever
if you don't know basically it's a skin
care product that has like this watery
consistency and it's used after
cleansing and toning but prior to serums
or moisturizers it's an essential step
to hydrate and prime your skin too
deeply absorb all of the ingredients
you're putting on your face so SK choose
facial treatment essence has an active
ingredient called Patera which fun story
was actually discovered at a sake
brewery in Japan so scientists noticed
that the workers though they were like
old and had wrinkly faces had these
super like soft and youthful hands so
Patera which was derived from this
natural fermentation process and made
all of these beautiful baby hands it's
now essential for faces and it works so
well because its properties are actually
very similar to the formula of human
skin I love this stuff it makes my skin
so much more hydrated and smooth and
radiant and I feel so much more
comfortable not wearing foundation
because finally on my skin tones even to
find out more about SK twos facial
treatment essence you can click on the
link below I'm Anna Akana stay awesome
Gotham